my name is aleem wal g and i'm the
practice manager for innovation at the
World Bank Institute and I am on the
Global Agenda Council for the future
government and our group has been
working on a framework called fast which
is done up governments be more
responsive and more agile and it
represents the at fist for a government
that is flattered the a is for a
government which is more agile the S is
a government which is more streamlined
and the T is a government which is tech
enabled and this is an idea to help
governments aspire to be more responsive
and more prepared to really respond to
the demands of their citizens and we
feel like in a world in which things are
changing so quickly government can't
stand still and can't continue to do
what it's doing and there are ways in
which it must embrace technology not be
afraid of social media but work with
social media but more importantly to
work with its citizens to co-create
solutions so I think the idea of what we
call vending machine government where
you pay your taxes and get service out
is gone and it's now a way to work with
your citizens work with civil society
private sector and other to create a
platform to be more effective as default